we've worked in about 80 countries we've
worked with thousands of human rights
defenders and the aim is always to turn
a personal story of abuse into a
powerful tool for justice my name is
yvette albertine tame and i'm the
executive director of witness which is a
global human rights organization based
in brooklyn witness was started about 20
years ago by the activist and musician
peter gabriel he traveled on the amnesty
human rights first tour and he was
traveling in countries with a very big
old clunky video camera and he started
talking to people it suffered human
rights abuses or had seen members of
their family killed and he realized when
they filmed their story that once that
story was on film that it could no
longer be buried or forgotten and that's
what started witness and shortly after
that the Rodney King incident happens in
America which is where an innocent
bystander filmed the police beating up a
man and it all of a sudden put the
handycam on the map and with the
realization that video can be such a
powerful tool and it changes the
equation in terms of documents and you
rights violations witness was started so
what we do is we partner with grassroots
groups because they're the ones who know
the issues best and they know the
solutions myth and we support them in
understanding how to use video to
document their stories and then what
happens with these videos is we help
them think strategically about who are
the people who need to see that video
for their for change to happen so it's
always aimed at creating policy change
or behavior change some of the changes
that witness has actually been able to
effect in its partnership with a local
human rights group in the Congo was
aimed at stopping the mobilisation of
child soldiers Congo has gone through a
very brutal civil war and the militias
were recruiting children to become part
of the militias so what we did is we
worked with a local organization called
a JDK we had the children tell their
stories
what happened to them after they were
recruited and that video was used in
eastern Congo to go from village to
village together with community
organizers and show what happens to
these children's to children once they
became soldiers and it they it helped
really educate families because they
were they were volunteering their
children into war because they didn't
realize that it wasn't a good thing the
other way that video was used is to
lobby the International Criminal Court
based in The Hague in the Netherlands to
arrest Thomas Lubanga who was a is is a
Congolese warlords that was actually one
of the perpetrators who was recruiting
children into war and he's now sending
child at an International Criminal Court
that was a successful effort and that
was a shared success because obviously
we were not the only ones who were
working at it but it was a major success
technology is an incredibly powerful
tool when you put it in the hands of
people on the ground who are trying to
create human rights change twenty years
ago the dream that witness has what what
what if every human rights defender
would have a camera in their hands
what would they document and what could
they change and today with video and
equipped mobile phones and devices in
the hands of literally billions of
people anyone can be a human rights
defender think about the students in
Iran think about how they actually
filmed what was going on and these were
the stories that the Iranian government
which was trying to repress and the fact
that everybody has seen for example the
video of the girl made a sultan who was
one of the demonstrators being killed
made it impossible for that regime to
deny those stories the flip side of that
is that the people who are filming and
being filmed are also at more danger
because what's now happening is the
images of these people are showing up in
many different places and sometimes that
can actually expose people to a lot of
risk it's very dangerous for people to
to documents for you know it's it it's
one thing if you're in the US and you're
filming a police officer and that person
says you're not allowed to do that it's
another thing if you're in Burma and or
in Tibet and actually
being known to to speak out can can have
can be a matter of life and death in
terms of what continues to be a really
big challenge for us I would mention two
things one the demand for our services
is always much bigger than what we can
provide or a small organization
we're very effective but there are 30
people and there's always more groups
out there that we can work with then the
people that we can actually serve so
we're now starting to create digital
toolkits to get sort of these skill sets
out to more people so they can be
effective when they use video the other
thing I would say is that the world of
Human Rights governments and the
perpetrators are also becoming very
adept at using technology so sometimes
when you look at places like Burma or
Iran it can be really an uphill battle
to continue to fight for a freedom of
expression but the thing I do say is
there's always in the end there's more
of us so we you know I think every
single person can make difference